[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift boy do
we have a great show for you today and a
great cast of characters as well
starting with a special delivery of 50
dogs we'll tell you how they made their
way from Kentucky to New York City also
two friends who made a name for
themselves at their senior living
facility what's the talent that made
these Two Fellas stand out we'll explain
also Star Trek actress senequa Martin
Greene has a touching tribute to the
groundbreaking Nichelle Nichols and the
passions that connect them also a family
that has made the same treat for 60
years what's their specialty plus a man
who stunned the Running World when he
qualified for the Boston Marathon in a
very unusual way what did he do we'll
talk about it all that plus our most
heartwarming videos the ones you just
need to see you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
hey there welcome to the uplift it's a
show that lifts you up you and me
included I'm Tony decopo we're going to
begin with those heartwarming videos the
ones you've got to see and we're going
to begin with this one it shows a Bride
named Laura in her wedding gown visiting
a senior facility to surprise her
grandmother Laura's grandmother has
Alzheimer's and was not able to go to
the wedding because she had been sick
around that time Laura says her grandma
has been her best friend though since
she was born and make sure to visit her
every day she can so of course she had
to see her on her wedding day
our next video shows eleven-year-old Zoe
at Disneyland Zoe there in the pink
shirt happens to be deaf she was shocked
when she walked up to Anna from Frozen
and Anna started to talk to her back in
Sign Language her mom said that most
characters do know how to say a little
bit like nice to see you so when Anna
started saying much more than that Zoe
was thrilled beyond words to be able to
talk to a princess and what did they
talk about Zoe's trip to Disney with her
family also their favorite rides of
course it's a great story
eliani moved to Japan when she was six
months pregnant and then the pandemic
hit that meant she couldn't see her mom
for two years because the borders of
many countries were closed well they
finally reunited for the first time and
her mom Solange got to meet her daughter
Alani now two years old there's the
moment
it's beautiful a mom named Tabitha
meanwhile was filming a sweet moment
when her newborn baby Ava did something
that absolutely shocked her
oh
[Music]
my God
Ava was just three weeks old when she
lifted her head up and planted a kiss
right on Dad's cheek in response to his
oh my God it's so sweet oh we need a
moment all right ever wonder how fortune
cookies are made well there's no better
company to show us than the Golden Gate
cookie company they make about 14
000 cookies a day and it's been doing so
for 60 years CBS San Francisco's Reid
Cowan shows us inside the factory
foreign
Golden Gate Cookie Company owner Kevin
Chan I don't come doesn't count the
cookies so we did 14
000 cookies a day
365 days a year and it's 60 years that's
more than 300 million cookies from the
same place in the same San Francisco
family choose a one not mixed about it
Nancy Chan is the cookie matriarch and
maker of a family that has become a San
Francisco institution known the world
over as Kevin approaches the 60th
anniversary since Nancy first opened the
doors he knows we should own a home all
I got a long way to live but she don't
have much time
73.
other fortune cookie makers moved out of
Chinatown into big factories selling to
Global restaurants many didn't make it
so the chance made a choice keep it
local why did you keep it right here in
the street I want people coming to San
Francisco and taste one of an authentic
San Francisco invention American
Products it could have been way richer I
could do that but that's not my point my
point is the communities the people the
community yeah communities where you
guys come from people like this family
from the Netherlands whose children saw
the Chan family cookies with wonder I
got people coming all over the world
where you come from Poland Poland this
is Alpine at San Francisco Planet so
whether you're a cook a baker or a
Candlestick maker do what you do as an
act of service and the payoff serving is
happiness happiness is serving brings
the best fortune and the sweetest treats
for the cookie stay for the fortune it's
a great piece coming up meet the rescue
dogs who made their way from flood
ravaged Kentucky to Manhattan's Hills
kitchen neighborhood yeah they are plus
what links Star Trek actress suniqua
Martin Greene with TB Pioneer Nichelle
Nichols who also starred on the same
show decades earlier it's more than just
acting
foreign
a group of 50 dogs make it out of
Kentucky after devastating flooding
there CBS New York's Dave Carlin has a
story
New York City welcomes this live cargo
special delivery
crowd of canines from Kentucky 50 of
them rescued from a state where its
eastern section is ravaged by flooding
this
Stella the puppy gets handed off it
feels so good two foster owners
Stephanie kajukum and Adam lernahan we
are excited to get our dog a friend for
a couple weeks this is toast and this is
butter the Hell's Kitchen animal rescue
Muddy Paws partners with shelter groups
in Kentucky North Carolina and Texas
helping ease severe overcrowding and
making sure the focus is on dogs of all
ages including older dogs who are at
risk of being put down annetta posnerova
is fostering a young and Tiny twosome
brother and sister puppies they are
named Lima and lentil pasirova was given
care instructions for the short time
they'll be together a little heart
attack every time you let them go but
but you know that's the goal that's why
I sign up for it this transport van will
leave empty of these guys but a delivery
is coming next week foster adopt donate
um please do so with any organization
everybody really really needs the help
right now and here's video we were sent
of Stella meeting the other dog in her
foster family Bailey settling in nicely
and here are Lima and lentil loving
their new foster home all with a second
chance at life
Lima and lentil the only thing cuter
than the dogs themselves are their names
actress Nichelle Nichols who died last
month left behind a lasting Legacy of
advocating for others and fellow Star
Trek actress siniqua Martin green is
following in her footsteps on screen and
off Caitlin O'Kane as our next story
I know this is
very much
one thousand percent actually a hero
saniqua Martin Greene is talking about
groundbreaking actress Nichelle Nichols
who recently died at age 89. they
appeared on the same show decades apart
but there are many parallels between the
two Star Trek actresses Nichols was one
of the first black actresses to star on
a TV show Martin Greene is the first
black female captain in Star Trek
history Nichols advocated for women and
people of color as a recruiter for NASA
Martin green is following in her
footsteps working to help women and
girls in stem there's such a dearth of
of women in stem careers
and and especially black black women
Latino women indigenous women it's it's
10 percent in stem careers today so we
need more of us out there and and that's
why I jumped at the opportunity to do
this she partnered with million girls
moonshot an organization that aims to
get 1 million more girls into stem
learning opportunities Frito-Lay has
donated one hundred thousand dollars to
further the program's Mission and to
send girls to space camp Martin green
surprised 16 girls the first group that
the organization is sending to space
camp presenting them with ceremonial
stars named after them I was so excited
for them to see my face and see see you
know my love and support for them I hope
this is an experience that they carry
with them hope that it's something that
sort of sets them on their path whatever
whatever that path may be or wherever it
may lead she said programs like this
wouldn't be possible without nickels
it's all because of her really because
she's the one that uh you know
helped integrate NASA way back then
um she's the one that said wait a second
I don't see what I need to be seeing I
don't see equality here and she
dedicated the rest of her life to it
from from 1977 to 2015
um to establishing these programs in
NASA and now here we are and these girls
can have this this kind of experience so
I am I'm very grateful to be a part of
it
Martin Greene hopes to continue Nichols
Legacy on and off screen I know she said
when when she was still here she said if
you if I've inspired you at all then I
just ask for you to continue this Legacy
so
of course now all of us that have been
inspired by her
um can do that and I hope that these
girls can do that too
[Music]
wow what a beautiful connection there
Caitlin nice piece coming up why the
books in this Chicago shop make an
impact as soon as you walk in there plus
two retirees who use their talents to
make a name for themselves in their
senior living facility and a man who
made history qualifying for a marathon
in an unusual and unexpected way what
did he do we'll show you stick around
you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
foreign
two friends in a senior living facility
didn't want to completely give up work
after they retired CBS San Francisco's
Andrea borba shows us how they get their
fix
the first rule of the wood shop at Stone
Ridge Creek Retirement is clean up your
sawdust we're about a third of the way
through this project
of the 79 201 residents of Pleasanton
only two are known as the Fix-It guys
eighty-year-old Rick Levesque and 95
year old Phil wire when Rick and his
wife Kathy moved in after a 40-year
career in nuclear physics at Lawrence
Livermore National Laboratory he needed
a hobby and fast after twiddling my
thumbs
for a few weeks I said I gotta do
something I'm going nuts
after building a desk and a model wooden
ship Rick found himself in the wood shop
five hours a day seven days a week just
to get off the sofa he and Phil carved
out a niche as the fix it guys for the
residents of Stone Ridge Creek it's a
Continuum of furniture pieces broken
lamps
all kinds of crazy things that are
broken come into this shop
we we have built a reputation with the
residents if it's broken bring it to the
shop they'll fix anything the craziest
thing they fixed one of them was a
gentleman's dentures
no joke what do you need
he pulls out his upper pallet
and he says my dentist hasn't been able
to fix the Burr on this tooth and it's
causing an ulcer not a problem for these
two the hardest was a wine barrel making
a bar out of it
today retired salesman Phil is working
on a hexagonal planter box but it's not
just about busy hands keeping Minds
young here it's mostly about this
there's a picture of it on the web and
this yeah he does everything I tell him
we we gripe about the music we gripe
about the sawdust on the floor all kinds
of things but we gripe with a smile and
we have a good time the work of serving
their fellow residents is a secondary
priority to camaraderie without this uh
I don't know what I would have done we
can fix anything in this shop but a
broken heart
they're hard to fix proving Liquid Nails
can hold more together than just wood we
were good friends
and we
had to learn that here
as always meaning and work it's a
beautiful piece there they say never
judge a book by its cover but at one
Chicago bookstore the covers make a
powerful impact here's Adriana Diaz with
the story
beside this
is true we've had parents and adults Cry
of the story you know we can be
emotional for some people emotional
because at kiddo the faces on the books
are black and brown and protagonists you
don't usually see a girl in a wheelchair
a mom in a hijab these are deliberate
choices says kiddo owner Kiwa nurula we
want every kid to feel reflected to feel
seen to feel included kids with
disabilities kids who are growing up in
foster care or have been adopted why did
you like these books because I like the
pictures on them with titles like queer
Heroes hair love and the ABCs of black
history beeswax crayons that show wow
the different skin Shades oh I wish I
had these growing up nerula introduced
us to some regulars Ryan has two
beautiful brilliant mothers and we have
an exceptional daughter and we want her
to be represented in the books that she
sees narula got into this work as a new
mom she didn't see options that
reflected her family so she made them do
you have a business background not at
all not at all this is her background
the Performing Arts where she also
embodied diversity in an unexpected way
I'm a retired princess Disney princess
if you ever wanted to know what happens
to them when they grow old when they
grow up when the Princess and the Frog
came out I was one of the princesses in
the show at Disneyland
you're always thinking about your
representation on stage and what that
could mean for a little kid who wants to
sing and dance Too your total is but
business is in her blood too stretching
back to her great grandfather Cynthia
Neal senior was a tailor and he had a
family in Tulsa Oklahoma he had a Taylor
shop on Blackwell Street and his family
was forced to flee during the massacre
of 1921. they made it to the south side
of Chicago where they reopened the
family business an entrepreneurial
Legacy that lives on here we don't want
any child to feel isolated in their
experience we want them to come into the
kiddo store and say oh wait I'm not the
only one
and when books have Heroes of all
backgrounds real world heroes are born
so many layers of that story great peace
Adriana coming up how running changed
one man's life and the unique way he
qualified for the Boston Marathon stick
around
foreign
er's life changed when he joined a
running club in a place that you might
not expect our David begno has his story
to say to Markel Taylor hey man what is
your secret to success he just might say
if you fall in life
get up and keep running
at 49 years old he is gearing up for the
Chicago Marathon this fall the streets
of California is where he trains that's
where I was raised right here not bad
for the views nice
beautiful but for nearly 18 years Taylor
could only dream of training in this
scenic city by the Bay from his window
at San Quentin State Prison when you got
sentenced did you think you were going
away for Life yes yeah I didn't think I
would never get out in 2001 he
physically assaulted his pregnant
girlfriend when she went to the ground
she said I felt like the baby stopped
moving the instant came on again like
what the hell did I do why did I do this
what the hell is going on so they
convicted you
for the death of your son yes
after you abused his mother yes
what was the sentence they made it 15
years of life it was a life-changing
moment for a man who says he was a
victim of violence as a boy we would get
abused if the dishes ain't washed or if
the house ain't clean over there and
clean to their specifications then we
would get whooped out of our sleep out
of your sleep out of our sleep did
something about that say to you that hey
hitting people is how you handle things
yes that was their connection there
growing up
did anybody tell you they were proud of
you
only my teachers
ironically it took going to prison for
him to hear words like that again inside
Taylor joined the 1 000 mile running
club it's a track team at the prison led
by volunteer coaches
his speed earned him a nickname Markel
the gazelle they called him it's a story
that will be highlighted in a
documentary coming out soon how many
races did you run in prison every month
we had a race
how many did you win I won every one of
them except for one
what were the euphoric feelings that you
got running in prison I got an emotional
High an emotional High an emotional it
was also because when I ran I ran to
honor my son it was like that you know
what you made a mistake
but keep running without faith in you to
be a better person
nice Marcel that Faith stemmed from the
kindness of his coaches we've been a
strong head up nice like Diana
Fitzpatrick great workout you have a
choice when you end up at a place like
San Quentin and you can just lay around
and let the time go by and wait for
something to happen or you can take
control of your life and try to do
something with it and Markel someone who
really chose to do something with his
life did it ever occur to you
that you showing him that he mattered
yeah is maybe why you got the best out
of him I guess
I always believed in Markel
and trusted him it makes me feel happy
I
yeah
with that support Markel Taylor did
something that has never been done at
San Quentin before
he ran a marathon that was so fast he
qualified for the 2019 Boston Marathon
and get this a month before the marathon
he was released on parole after serving
nearly 18 years
special permission to race I couldn't
really enjoy Boston because I was still
being happy and appreciative
of just being free well this spring he
went back and ran Boston again off
parole and truly a free man what was the
time then
252 flat
and that is a time so Speedy he placed
in the top five percent of all the
runners it's now your drug exactly it's
not my drug but it's a positive good
drug that don't hurt people that's right
it helps people
he's been given a new starting line at
life
he's now got his own one-bedroom
apartment where he's starting to cook
again
he got promoted at the grocery store
where they took a chance on him his boss
told us he is a humble Warrior have a
good day thank you new opportunities for
a new man who's moving in the right
direction what do I see in your eyes
someone that stopped running that
don't need to run no more they can stand
up to all my fears and anxieties I feel
like
I signed the pledge of being non-violent
and I know that not only do I owe it to
myself and the people who are victimized
in my lifetime
I owe it to all those who are counting
on me and people who are looking for me
to be a positive influence in their life
all right what do I look like
what is my Tombstone gonna say later
when I pass what would you like for it
to say
that
he felt but he got up and he changed the
life of a lot of human beings for the
better
[Music]
that's why I keep doing it and sometimes
I have to do stuff like this to continue
to validate myself this type of stuff
helps keep you accountable doesn't it
exactly that's what it is the
accountability yeah
that's what it is
[Music]
and that is our show I want to say I
hope it brightens your day and lifted
you up but I know it did with pieces
like that stick around for our next
uplift in the meantime I'm gonna go for
a little walk and find some more good
stories see you again soon
foreign